hey you guys it's max from Max Tech and
we just got our hands on the brand new
Galaxy S 10 II and we're gonna be
comparing it to the iPhone 10 our let's
start out by getting an unboxing a lot
of reviewers are calling these phones
budget options but in reality at $750
for each one that's not that budge at
least in my book but with each one of
these there are some features that were
cut compared to the premium flagship but
I'll cover that in just a bit I want to
start out by just giving you guys my
first impressions in the hand and this
thing is definitely smaller and lighter
than the iPhone 10 are it also feels
thinner in the hand even though if you
look at the specs I'm sure there isn't
that much of a difference and they look
very similar but I can tell the
difference and I think the weight helps
along with that on the back we have
their prism white color and it's I don't
know if you're catching that with Dean
it looks nice it's a pearlescent color
and then this has kind of painted in as
well it's silver here instead of just
being black holding these two
side-by-side the 10 ARS bezels look
really archaic and huge and along with
that same thing with the knotch whereas
the cutout is nice and small and a lot
less distracting even though both of
these have topic line CPUs we do have
some other differences in specs the
iPhone 10 R has three gigs of RAM
compared to six gigs on s 10 e same with
the storage it's also doubled 64 gigs
compared to 128 gigs and the ste also
has expandable storage with microSD
cards up to 512 gigabyte so you can add
so the S 10 e is all set up and just
like with the S 10 plus I'm getting 12
Google downloads a bunch of Samsung
downloads even though I didn't log into
my samsung account and that's one thing
that you don't have to deal with with
the iPhones is all the extra bloatware
and all those notifications and all that
other stuff that comes with Samsung I've
heard they've made it better and I'm on
day 5 of my switch from my iPhone 10s
max to the S 10 plus and there's been a
lot of good changes and bad changes make
sure you guys subscribe and enable those
notifications if you guys want to check
out that video that will be hitting soon
even setting up this fingerprint it is
really quick to read compared to the
ultrasonic sensor wow this is fast I'm
literally just hitting the button for I
don't know a split second
that turns on the phone and that's
enough to authenticate my fingerprint
this is way quicker than the ultrasonic
sensor let's try the s10 plus the
ultrasonic and if I just hold it like
this okay it didn't go that time you
guys see how much of a delay that is
face IDs more reliable than the
ultrasonic and maybe a little bit
quicker too but it's kind of close but
it's still two steps tap and pull or is
with this thing wow that's fast while I
have the s10 Plus out if you're curious
about the size differences there is a
fairly big difference in size this thing
fits in my hands almost feels like it's
too small but if it's pretty much
perfectly where as this thing is really
large even for my large hands the power
button is way up here definitely a large
two-handed device and as far as the
cutouts
I definitely preferred the s10 ease and
the s tens compared to that pillbox
shape with the SN plus now as far as
bezels I'm pleasantly surprised by the
s10 II doesn't look that thick with the
S 10 + + S 10 they have the curved edges
with infinity edge and that just makes
it kind of look like there's no bezel
when you're looking at it but it's just
a trick because the phone is has the
screen slightly bent and I want to
compare the screen brightness to the 10r
so went into the power savings to turn
on high performance so we can max out
the LCDs brightness but this is where I
found something interesting there is no
high performance mode like there is on
the s10 + what just says will allow you
to have the maximum screen brightness in
resolution but I'll use more battery so
that's actually missing out of the
settings which is weird so here is the
difference in brightness and I'm quite
surprised the s10 II definitely does not
look as bright as the iPhone 10 are and
we do have the auto brightness turned
off so the iPhone 10 R has pretty much
no color shift but definitely a lot of
brightness shift whereas the s10 II
definitely has some color shift but the
brightness does not change that much
that might just be the difference
between olla technology and LCD so now
let's compare the display quality the
iPhone 10 R has a 720p display compared
to 1080p on the S
and now I have a high quality YouTube
video open it is a 60 frames per second
HDR video and we can really see the
difference here both of them are
actually pulling 1080p from YouTube so
the iPhone 10 R is oversampling but even
still I definitely see more sharpness
more detail on the S and es displayed
along with that a lot more punch in the
colors more contrast man it's specially
visible here and even though the iPhone
10 our screen is getting brighter in
some of the spots we still have more
highlight details so in like bright
areas like clouds you see all the
details of cloud not just a white blob
in the sky so colors are definitely
popping the dark areas are much darker
because we have an OLED display compared
to an LCD and here especially in that
shot it really looks just washed out the
colors and the contrast compared to the
s10 these display eat right there
especially that is like grey reddish
from the flaring where this is pure
black and watching this scene right here
I mean this looks gorgeous on here the
detail and the colors compared to the
standard LCD so now it's time for the
speaker test both are laying down with
her bottom firing speakers coming
outwards and the top speakers pointed
towards me so you guys can kind of hear
a volume difference and I'll give you
guys my commentary that's 10 plus was
very impressive and very loud so I'm
excited to see how the s10 II does
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to be completely honest I'm really not
sure they seemed similar maybe you guys
can let me know what you think in the
comments section below of course you're
listening just through this mic but it's
a similar difference between these two
but both of them sound good and get
decently loud so let's wrap up this
comparison by talking about the cameras
now both of them have front-facing
cameras obviously but the SNe does not
have that pill-shaped cut out meaning it
doesn't have a depth sensor here
compared to the iPhone 10 R which has
the full true depth sensing this whole
array of sensors appear so let's start
out by just taking a selfie and you guys
let me know which one you think looks
better now on the back type 110 are just
has a single lens it's the same standard
lens on the iPhone 10 s whereas the S 10
has dual cameras we have the same
standard and ultra wide camera that's on
the S 10 and s 10 plus but we are
missing that telephoto camera now even
though we don't have the telephoto
camera you can still take portrait shots
with both of these they are wider
portrait mode shots one other difference
is the 10 R you can only take portrait
shots of people whereas the S any will
let you take photos of objects let us
now which look better in the comments
section below so overall we're really
impressed with a galaxy s 10 T
especially when we compare it
side-by-side with the iPhone 10 are not
only do we have twice daram twice a
storage expandable storage a headphone
jack the same price point but we also
get a much nicer only to display that's
higher resolution and can support HDR
because of all of that the S setting is
definitely a better buy than the iPhone
10 are we will be doing more comparisons
between these two more videos on the SN
e so if you have any questions or any
comments let us know down below make
sure you guys hit that subscribe button
and enable those notifications this has
been max with max sec and we'll see you
in the next video
[Music]